you can't be insecure about something
unless there's someone else making this
judgment otherwise there would be
nothing to be insecure about naming who
owns that insecurity takes it from this
really amorphous thing to like it's John
really wow it is John when I was selling
one of the businesses I started playing
these voices just one particular
entrepreneur that I know and I was like
he's gonna think that this isn't enough
money I had to write down his name and
say like will I let this person stop me
from exiting this company when I saw it
it just seemed so small and I was like
no this guy is going to influence my
decisions going to change the rest of my
life because of a voice I have in my
head that he doesn't even know I'm
thinking about him